[Musik]
also ich muss dazu sagen von den sieben
mitteilen sind sechs von harris
bundeswehr leistungssportlern erzählt
waren das ist großartig so erfolgreiche
spiele hat es aus der sicht des bllv
noch nicht gegeben
und ich finde dass also wirklich eine
sehr sehr erfreuliche bilanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja man der schlüssel zum erfolg war
natürlich trotzdem alles nochmal
ausholen ihm vorschlägt ich habe die
medaille aber nur meiner vorstieß zu
verdanken
genau im nach dem boden sieht so gut
ausgeschaut für mich heuer statt sich
enttäuscht weil ich gewusst habe sogar
mit am ein zeichen vorstieg ist es
unwahrscheinlich dass ist eine medaille
land und da ja die moderne doch noch mal
zeigen was sie draufhaben der welt
zeigen wir sehr guter form bin und ich
glaube das habe ich getan und habe
irgendwie dann doch das glück des
tüchtigen kraft und genau mit einer mit
alle bedeutung
es war definitiv mein sportliches
karriere-highlight also das war
der werbung vor der folge für mich und
sowohl emotional war es ist für mich der
emotionalste wettkampf und einfach der
weg davor bis man wirklich auf dieser
dame stehen dürfen und wein langer und
es hat sich jetzt so schön bosse
medaille ausgezahlt ich bin noch mit
matura
mit 19 jahren ins bundesheer kommt jetzt
bin ich zehn jahre dabei
also wirklich ohne das bundesheer könnte
für leistungssportler den sieben karate
doch randsportart ist also bin sehr
dankbar dass sie diese möglichkeit anja
[Musik]
mal führte